welcome back so we're talking about this
roadmap control for societal scale
challenges roadmap 2030 and IEEE control
system Society publication and we're
zooming into the chapters of this
roadmap so I'm really excited about this
one so this video is going to zoom into
chapter three technological Trends which
I think is one of the more exciting kind
of areas in general is technology is
advancing at such a rapid Pace in so
many fields sometimes it can feel
overwhelming even as someone who is kind
of in the metal middle of these
technological developments I feel
overwhelmed but it's also really really
exciting the tools we have access to to
solve societal scale challenges are
getting better so fast it's really
really exciting so this is a chapter I'm
really excited to tell you about and I
hope you have as much fun as I have
making this
so just some of the pieces pieces of
chapter 3 technological Trends this is
really talking about what are the large
kind of broad developments in the world
that are advancing our technical
capabilities
so things like Ai and Big Data this is
undoubtedly changing pretty much every
field of engineering every industrial
landscape all of science and technology
is being Advanced by Ai and Big Data
that's you know this has as much
potential many people think as cell
phones or the internet or you know the
electric light so really exciting and
we're still wrapping our heads around
what are the societal scale implications
of AI and big data and how are we going
to be able to use these to solve
societal challenges that we couldn't
solve before
Electrify everything this is a really
cool Trend and a very uh powerful Trend
with a lot of momentum that increasingly
every sector of our society is becoming
more and more electrified so there are
strains on our power grid distributed
power generation sources and power
drawing uh you know sinks are becoming
increasingly complex as everything is
increasingly electrified and connected
so that's a really cool and important
technological trend
uh engineering biology this is a really
really exciting field this has some of
the most sci-fi futuristic potential uh
applications of any of these Trends I
guess all of these really do but
engineering biology really is at this
interface of how do you engineer in
biological systems and how do you
engineer biological systems to solve
engineering tasks how do you make
organisms that generate uh you know fuel
sources or medicines super cool super
sci-fi and advanced but it's actually
real world this is this is a it's
reality now we're actually doing this
and it's very exciting uh and then
robots in the real world so the promise
of having you know robots in our lives
has been around forever uh in in at
least modern science fiction so if you
think about the Jetsons or you know kind
of 1950s 1960s concepts of the future
there are robots Among Us
and it took a long time but increasingly
robots are finally getting good enough
to be able to work in unstructured
uncertain environments actually have
some autonomy and some shared human
robot decision making and uh really
really exciting Trend I think you know
we're all going to see this this uh
become a Big Driver of technology in the
future okay so that's what's in this uh
this chapter and I'm just gonna again
zoom into little bits and pieces but
this is a pretty broad chapter it's
about 50 pages about 20 of this road map
so again download this yourself read it
uh you know see what you think about
these technological Trends and see if
you think that there's any missing or if
there are areas in here that you're
really excited about maybe there's
connections to the Future problems and
societal challenges that you know were
not made in this that you want to make
this is a you know hopefully kind of a
living idea space that you can
contribute to as well
so one that I think is super exciting is
AI and Big Data this is you know I'm a
researcher in this field especially in
how machine learning artificial
intelligence and big data can impact
modeling and control systems engineering
systems but this is undoubtedly one of
the largest areas of rapid growth in
science and technology today so you know
crazy examples like taking a still image
of the Mona Lisa and making her come to
life with machine learning things that
were science fiction 10 years ago are
science reality today and this is just
one of many examples of things that we
didn't think would be possible that we
can now right chat GPT can write
brilliant essays they can help
collaborate with us on ideas they can
make itineraries if you're traveling to
a far-off location
the possibilities are endless and we're
still wrapping our heads around how we
integrate this into Control Systems how
we use these to solve societal scale
challenges okay
one of the things I like about this this
chapter and this road map in general
is it thinks about not just what are the
big trends but what is the technology
driving these Trends so for example in
machine learning if you think about the
rapid rise of machine learning just in
the last 10 years or so there are some
pretty uh reasonable Baseline
technologies that have advanced that
have enabled our advances in machine
learning things like hardware gpus and
tpus graphics processor units and tensor
processing units have you know our
Hardware is much much better
we have better neural network
architectures and math algorithms
we have industry investment in open
source software and things like that and
there's many others but you know these
are just some of the the things that are
actually driving this technological
Trend in machine learning
um you know other things like Benchmark
data sets this imagenet data set and
things like that like the open AI gym or
mujoku are driving advances in these
fields as Benchmark problems okay so so
it's really important to think not just
what is developing technologically but
what are the foundations that are
enabling those technological trends like
hardware and software and algorithms
and especially in big data and
artificial intelligence we have this
explosion of let's say neural network
architectures and algorithms and
software and so really trying to
understand in a principled way how do we
apply these to systems with physics to
you know do physics and form machine
learning to develop control laws for
systems that have symmetries and
conservation laws and are governed by f
equals m a this is really important to
start developing these Ai and ml tools
into our engineering landscape and
especially into our control theory
landscape so that we can start getting
the Best of Both Worlds okay so that's a
really exciting Challenge and area
uh biotechnology is another one that I
think is just absolutely fascinating
bioengineering
um is one of these fields that a number
of decades ago seemed you know kind of
Science Fiction but advances in
especially control theory for synthetic
biology are driving really new
capabilities where we can actually start
to use the mechanisms and Machinery of
life in an engineering sense to build
engineering circuits out of biological
materials and if you think about it the
most efficient means of energy
conversion on Earth you know from
sunlight into into energy is is
biological right plants have covered the
surface of the Earth algae in the ocean
how do we harness this for uh again
solving these societal scale problems
for energy for climate for developing
new medicines and health treatments all
kinds of applications here really the
you know the sky is the limit and I
highly recommend you you read about
these and get uh integrated and
understanding on these topics because
this is going to change the world and
you know you don't necessarily have to
be developing in this field but we
should be aware of the technological
trends that are changing the world this
is absolutely one of them super
fascinating uh and challenging and
important area of Bio technology
engineering biology synthetic biology
some of the control theorists I respect
the most have moved into this field
that's a strong signal to me again of
the importance and kind of interest and
excitement that's going on in this field
and then of course robotics robotics is
a super exciting field it's almost a
field uh you know a field on its own it
is a field on its own control theory is
clearly Central to robotics
these are control systems that are
governed by physics very highly
constrained optimization problems go
into making robots work and now in the
modern era these robots have to deal
with uncertain environments they have to
work in unstructured environments they
have to make decisions alongside humans
they have to be you know safe and
certifiably safe
and of course we also are going to be
using machine learning and artificial
intelligence in our development of
robots these robots are going to be
learning from their environments and
adapting and so it's a really
interesting and Rich kind of
multi-physics multi-scale
multi-technology playground but also
really really important there's a lot of
societal scale challenges that we
believe robots will be at the center of
so super exciting
um you know again important area for us
all to be aware of what the trends are
you know what is the history where is it
going and that's something I think you
know that this roadmap really does a
great job of is providing that context
specifically where do control theorists
fit in how do we start working together
you know to advance and utilize and
leverage these Technologies for these
societal scale challenges super exciting
I highly encourage you to read more
about this thank you